What’s that bright thing in the sky?
Is it ablazing chariot?
An all-seeing eye? Maybe a burning ball of gas?
At different points in history, humanshave
believed the sun to be all of these things.
They may not have agreed on what the sunwas,
but ancient cultures recognized
its power to sustain life,
so it was appropriately held in a
place of honor in most mythologies.
Whether people thought it was a divine being
or a nuclear fusion factory, which we now
know to be the case, the stories all had one
lesson in common: don’t look directly at it.
Energy from the sun gives heat, offers a
bright reprieve from the darkness of night,
and serves as the base
for our entire food chain.
Basically, the sun is central to so many myths
becauseit provides all the energy we
need to live. But it makes you wonder.
Where does all that energy even come from?
Well, let’s have fellow astronomer Matt
O’Dowd from PBS Digital’s Space Time
explaina little about the
source of the sun’s power.
The Sun is a gigantic nuclear
reactor, as is every star.
And I do mean gigantic. It's the same as
every nuclear bomb on the planet went off
roughly 20 million times every second. It's
been doing that for 5 billion years so far,
with another 5 billion to go. The secret
to this incredible energy production
comes from the most famous
equation of all time:
Einstein's E =mc².
This tells us that mass is just
another form of energy
and that every little bit of mass
contains an enormous amount of energy.
And that's the type of energy
released in the center of the Sun.
The tiny nuclei of the tiniest atom - hydrogen
- are smashed together at incredible speeds,
allowing them to overcome
their natural repulsion
andstick together due
to the strong nuclear force.
The result is a nucleus of helium plus a LOT
of energy. This is a bit of stellar alchemy:
the elements of the periodic table
are forged in thehearts of stars,
although most of the interesting ones get
made by stars much bigger than our sun,
before being blasted out in supernova explosions.
The energy produced in these
fusion reactions takes the form of
gamma ray light. This light slowly makes its
way out of the super-dense interior of the Sun.
It takes 10s of thousands of
years for each photon of light
tobounce its way out. And then takes
about eight minutes to reach the earth
once it escapes. So the warmthyou
feel on your face when you step out
into asummer day was actually
produced in the core ofthe Sun
before the dawn of human civilization.
And since that dawn, cultures
have been worshipingthe sun
and its light as a powerful deity.
Think about it. The world seems to
come alive when the sun is in the sky,
and its reliable return every day
provides a sense of order to the universe.
Of course, when ancient Indian cultures
in the Vedic period about 3000 years
ago looked at the Sun, they knew nothing
about the strong nuclear force. Instead,
they saw the highest representation
of Agni, the Vedic god of fire.
Often depicted with two heads and riding a ram,
Agni was one of the most powerful Vedic gods,
second only to Indra, the god of the heavens.
In the other levels of his power, Agni
existed on Earth as regular fire and in
the sky as lightning. In his triumvirate
form, he came to represent theconnection
between the mundane and the divine.
Just like the fire and sun he personified,
Agni was feared as an agent of destruction,
but also revered for his ability to nourish.
But Agni wasn’t always pleased by
his association with destruction.
In one story from the Vedas, a demon asked Agni
to confirm his rightful betrothal
to Puloma, wife of the sage Bhrigu.
It was a complicated situation, and Agni could
neither confirm nor deny the demon’s claim,
so the demon stole Puloma away.
She made it back okay, but Bhrigu
still cursed Agni to devour and destroy
everything in his path. Enraged, Agni protested
by withdrawing all of his fire from the world,
including the fire that humans
used to sacrifice to the gods.
Obviously, this would not do, so Brahma,
the supreme creator of the universe,
altered the curse so that Agni’s fire
would purify everything he touched.
Agni isn’t the oldest solar deity — it’s likely
impossible to know who that first one was.
The Vedic culture was just one of many
who devoted a lot of time, energy,
and resources to worshiping the sun.
The Incas who lived in modern day
Peru from the 12th to 16th centuries
incorporated the Sun in so
many aspects of theirculture,
from holidays to agriculture to politics.
Their sun god, Inti, was one of
their most powerful deities, again,
second only to his father,
the creator god Viracocha.
The Incan royal family was said to
be directly descended from Inti,
so his temples were the most grand.
The Temple of the Sun in the capital city Cuzco
was made of ornately carved stone and
filled with extravagant gold objects,
all of which was plundered when the Spanish
conquered the Inca Empire in the 1500s.
Inti was honored every year with a
week-long festival called Inti Raymi.
The festival includes fasting,
sacrificing scores of animals,
parading decorated statues of Inti,
and of course singing and dancing.
It’s a party, after all, but it was
also meant as an appeal to Inti.
The festival,which is still held today,
happens In June, around the southern
hemisphere’s winter solstice.
In their celebration they were begging Inti
to return to them in the darkest time of year
Of course, not all solar
deities were depicted as male.
In Japanese shinto religion,
Amaterasu isconsidered
the most powerful kami, or divinespirit.
She is the ruler of the Takama no Hara, the
high celestial plain where all the kami live.
Born from the left eye of her father
Izanagi as he purified himself in a stream,
Amaterasu is also said to be the
ancestor of theJapanese ruling family.
In one myth, Amaterasuhides in a
cave after the storm god Susanoo
pullssome distasteful
younger brother shenanigans.
Without Amaterasu’s warming light, the world
fellinto decay and evil spirits roamed the Earth.
The other kami tried everything they could
think of to draw Amaterasu out of the cave,
from using roosters to trick her into thinking
it was dawn to bribing her with sparkly jewels.
She was eventually lured out
of hiding by the kamis’ raucous
laughter as they watched the goddess
Amenouzume perform a naughty dance.
In Baltic mythology, the sun was represented by
Saule, the mother and ruler of the heavenly beings
whodetermined the well-being
of all life on earth.
Depicted as a blond woman
wearing a golden shawl and crown,
Saule lived in a palace at the end of the sea,
where she tended a garden of golden apples.
According to legend, Saule in her divine radiance
would ride across the sky in a chariot pulled by
two tireless white horses who didn’t
sweat. Her daughters were the planets
and her husband was the moon. Though in
somestories, Saule and the moon are divorced
because he decided to pursue the goddess of
dawn, aka the morning star or the planet Venus.
Saule was far from the only solar deity to ride
avehicle across the sky. The Greek gods Helios
and Apollo were both shown riding
a chariot throughthe heavens.
The Egyptian sun god Ra was
saidto ride in a solar barge
during the day. At night,he sailed through the
underworld until he returned to the sky in the
east. Cave carvings from the neolithic
and bronze ages depicting the Sun on
a ship passing through stars show that the concept
of a solar barge has existed for millennia.
Given how important the sun
was to these ancientcultures,
it’s no surprise that a solar
eclipse, a phenomenon where the moon
blocks the light ofthe Sun from our earthly view,
would be a dramatic and meaningful
event. As Ra passed through theEgyptian
underworld in his boat, the evil
god Apep would try to devour him.
Eclipses happened whenhe succeeded,
but Ra always managed to escape.
Plenty of other cultures explained
eclipses as something eating the sun.
In Vietnamese mythology,that
creature is a frog or toad.
In ancientChina, it was a
dragon. In Hindu mythology,
the god Rahu was beheaded,
and he swallowed thesun
as his severed head flew through the
air. In various parts of the world,
including parts of China, South America,
and even at the Griffith Observatory in LA,
it’s customary to make loud
noises like banging pots and pans
to scare away the animal or demon trying
to eat or steal the sun during an eclipse.
But to the Fon people of modern day Benin, a
solar eclipse was cause to celebrate, not fear.
Also known as the Dahomey, the Fon
believed that a supreme being named
Nana Buluku created the universe
and gave birth to Mawu and Lisa.
Mawu created the Earth with the help of a
great snake and then invited her brother Lisa
to help her populate it with their children:
gods, goddesses, plants, animals, and humans.
The humans treated poor Mawu so terribly that
she fled to the sky and inhabited the moon.
But, she took pity on them and
sent her brother/baby daddy Lisa
to teach the humans how to build shelter,
use tools, and farm. When he was done,
he went up to the sky and inhabited
the sun to be close to his sister/wife.
When Mawu first went to visit
Lisa, she blocked his sunlight,
but it was okay because the fruit
of that union… was literal fruit.
They were the seeds that humans needed
to plant once they mastered farming.
And now when there’s a solar eclipse,
the Fon who hold onto the old ways hope
there might be another gift from above.
From fiery gods of destruction to sweet
life givers who farm apples and protect
orphans, the sun has been a central figure
in some of the world’s most enduring myths.
That’s because, as humans, there would be no
life without that nuclear force in the sky.
I guess that makes it pretty important…
but in the grand scheme of things,
it’s still just a boring, middle-aged G-type star.
To learn just how not-special the sun is,
checkout our collab episode with
PBS Space Time
about galactic habitable zones,
featuring your otherfavorite
astrophysicist host: Matt O’Dowd.
I’llalso be there to answer the question:
if there are aliens in the Milky Way,
where should they be?
While you’re there, be sure to check out theother episodes.
Space Time explores the outer
reaches of space, the craziness of astrophysics,
and the possibilities of sci-fi, and anything
else you can think of beyond Planet Earth.